uh we have a guest today and I merge
please introduce our guests uh yes we we
have uh uh on with us today streamer
um and uh a frequent guest of the
simcast and uh
influencer is that is that fair uh star
Fair uh the woman no don't say
influencer that's
how about under the end how about under
the influencer is that good yeah I have
seen you it looks really shitty because
I don't use zoom so I don't know like
you're fine it looks like that but hey
look at us you're fine yeah don't worry
you just it's gonna be okay it looks
like it's uh weird I don't know whatever
I don't care as long as you guys know
what email looks weird looks looks fine
I don't think influence was a bad word
though I've seen you post a lot of
Twitter things about you know trying to
influence people to stop trying to [__]
kids that's pretty good that is in a way
influencing people right like hey maybe
yeah shop less kids next off yeah let's
do that that's that's okay in that
context but I just hate that [__]
word because it's stupid Everyone's an
influencer everyone is Famous online now
so I mean I mean I guess that's true
that's a good point uh it's just how
many people you're influencing right
yeah I mean there's people with like 50
million followers and or like 4 million
on Tick Tock I've never seen them in my
life so are you on Tick Tock I don't get
Tick Tock I don't know um I they banned
me at like I had like 130k wait they
banned you well first thing for saying
spicy things probably right honestly I
don't know why I think it's because I
posted my Instagram that was like the
last straw like you're not allowed I
guess even you're not allowed you're not
allowed to plug you're not allowed to
plug your your other stuff I guess I
have no idea I have no clue they never
tell you why um I still had videos and
appeal from like last year that they
never even looked at so I don't I have
no idea but that was right after they
did that so
who knows I have a backup but I don't
really I'll put I've been posting on it
more because I said it was going to get
banned so I just been posting whatever
and seeing if they take it down but yeah
they haven't yet I only had one I had a
tick tock for one video that I uploaded
one time when I was dancing that Nicki
Minaj it was when I was shaving my beard
off yeah for something and I was like
all right you know you're gonna shave
your beard off you got to get one Hitler
stash photo because you know I'm
immature and uh I took the video with
the Nicki Minaj song and I think I was
immediately banned from Tick Tock for
days you got banned just from that one
well yeah well I was dancing it with a
Hitler mustache on in black and white to
Nicki Minaj but Charlie Chaplin mustache
that was not fair they [__] you up bro
that's what happened I made all my cats
are on tickets I made one Tick Tock
video also and it was me saying Tick
Tock is for [__] over and over again
and I'm it still is verified and it's
still up he's very super weird that it's
still up but really I really did do that
I checked the other day it's still up
apparently so so they don't really have
rules they don't enforce them equally as
usual like with all these platforms so
you really don't know have you tried
being a teacher grooming kids they let
those on Tick Tock do that you'll be on
front page yeah if you try being a
grooming teacher be a grooming teacher
well one of the most disturbing things
that I've seen was this is recent too
where there's like women breastfeeding
their kids that are like old enough to
Chew steak and talking about their only
fans at the same time like on a live
bro wait wait wait we just got convicted
of that there was that was doing [__]
like that so bizarre yeah there was a
woman that got convicted of that these
chicks you get me that yeah some some
woman got arrested and convicted for
making like sexualized videos that were
breastfeeding and they were always like
they were just always pushing a certain
line for what but for what like well
because she started saying really
overtly sexual stuff towards the end and
they're like yeah towards the end of her
little career there or whatever you want
to call it and it was starting to be
like okay this is just pornography like
this is you know this is just I've seen
three just in one day so so okay I don't
know this so just real quick
so so what you're saying is there's tick
tocks where they use it under the guise
of like you know breastfeeding is
Perfectly Natural but in reality they're
using it as a way because of because it
you know if a breastfeeding video in my
opinion has like like a million views
it's mostly not dudes looking at not
people looking at them what a great mom
it's weirdos right yeah yeah they know
that they know you
you're not giving tips you're not like
you can
and they don't I mean this one kid had
to be like six five or six maybe four
but
sorry sorry just I apologize because
this this is I did not hear anybody
a five-year-old breastfeeding well yeah
you don't want your kid to be
underdeveloped but what about the team
and that's what I mean he could choose
State
at that point you got some of your uh
that's at that point you have some of
your permanent teeth coming in yeah it's
so weird and they don't take it down
either it's wild well it's Tick-Tock
it's it's find it on there every day
yeah every day I don't even know what
you search because it was just coming up
I'm not gonna first off I'll probably
promised you something I am not going to
be searching for that well I can explain
to you why they don't take it down yeah
but it's just there it's there it pops
up organically and I know what you mean
I think like it's in the algorithm where
it'll yeah yeah yeah yeah that's [__]
up Tick tock's operating as it's
designed that's why they're not taking
it down it's a Chinese design cultural
septic tank so you know like people
always will say well you're one of the
one making the algorithm that is not
true because I was working with people
that try to catch Predators online and I
signed up as a 13 year old girl didn't
do anything different phone not mine the
first things that came up were like kids
dancing with tons of makeup on tube tops
sexual weird [__] I didn't do anything
like I didn't that that's not true
that's not at all no there's um when we
were hanging out with uh Alex Rosen who
does predator poachers um when we went
to Austin and he I think we were going
out so Royce was getting ready I was
already ready to go out so me and Rose
were just sitting there talking and he
was like upset because he's always on
the grind trying to catch these dudes
and he's like I think I just found
another dude man he followed my decoy
account he's like showing me in real
time how he does it on Instagram but
then he goes check this out he's like
you want to see how easy like it is to
hook up with child pornographers on here
and I'm like not really but sure like
like you mean just show he's dude he
clicks his [__] the following list
that this guy is following and there's
literally Pizza symbols and CP in the in
the names of the Instagram accounts and
they don't post anything on Instagram
but they post like harmless pictures of
random kids if they take off the
internet and then like like people
follow these accounts and then they send
you a link to Telegram and then you go
on Telegram and that's like dude he's
got these guys clocked so when he goes
on now he's like look at the follower
list boom boom bang he makes lit like
he's a [__] site he's like a Charlie
Kelly with the Pepe Sylvia It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia he just does our
cork board of pedos behind him and these
decoys and he's just like and then we're
going here and we're gonna go up through
Appalachian I got like nine guys we're
gonna hit along the way and then we're
gonna Circle back and get another 12 and
you're like Jesus this guy never said I
would totally do that yeah he's the best
I mean I do now but not to that extent
but it's very easy to get them to start
talking to you even after like I always
make sure to tell them I'm 13 so there's
no mistaking it and they do not care
like yeah it's wild it's [__] up man
it's why first time you look you should
hook up with Alex Rosen I'm sure he's
always looking for help uh and also on
top of that like I was watching just
another one like Trilogy media who
normally they're normally you know it's
like a basketball dude and like the the
the that little Jewish magician dude
they used to go after call scammers and
[__] like that okay but they did a petos
thing the amount of people like in a
small like area that they it would say I
think 20 people like this is [__] bad
Rosen drops two new catches a week and
he's behind he's always behind he can't
he can't even keep up with all of the
catches which is like stagger it's
mind-numbing to me how many people are
Tick Tock is one of the worst but also
what's really bad like if you have kids
if they play Roblox dude Roblox is a
cesspool of predators
yeah I get I guess I can there chat and
stuff like like they have the okay
yeah I know two people in my real life
that has happened to their kids of
people saying inappropriate [__] to them
on that game and yeah they'll pretend
like they're kids and then they'll start
asking them weird sexual questions like
it's sick like if they're everywhere
everywhere they have so much access to
kids now it's wild but like Marsha
saying earlier by Design I mean it's by
Design right I mean it's a straight
pipeline it's it's a straight pipeline
to do it look at that they wanna they
wanna they wanna get parents out of
decision making in schools too I mean
it's what it's it's what it is but I
mean this shit's belong because I mean
obviously I'm 40 I'm gonna [__] Tick
Tock I don't give a [__] but yeah but
but I guess that's an issue because it's
basically just it's the playground for
this a literal a literal playground
where they're both some guy with a weird
mustache splitting up in his irocy and
go like hey want to do a tick tock
challenge it's weird it also it's also
bad because like kids nowadays are not
not as close with their parents they're
not getting taught good values they're
not getting taught good lessons so it's
like I remember being a kid like when
the 56 came age came to you know we
started having like AOL dial up and [__]
and like bro there were petos back then
they were trying to bang us you know
what I mean but like we had decent we
would go like yeah wow dude you're
pretty [__] weird and I'm just gonna
report you this is [__] like you know
even as a kid you're like this is
[__] weird dude I don't know what
you're into I know me and my friend used
to do on Yahoo chat because Yahoo chat
was like to me the OG disgusting
Cesspool of perverts and like I was like
9 10 and we would talk to these dudes
tell them that we were like 12 whatever
and have them come meet us at like a few
houses down from her because it was like
this weird abandoned house it was
boarded up Vines everywhere they would
come almost every single one we would
hide on her porch it'd be like two in
the morning like dying laughing at these
dudes like driving around the block
walking they keep looking and they look
nervous but they would still go up to
the [__] house even though it looks
shitty and decrepit they still did it
like they still wanted to meet it's like
it's like one of those houses like like
when people would like steal a credit
card number and that's where they have
the packages shipped right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like the house from
The Burbs all the time which was
probably really dangerous but probably
probably yeah baiting yeah little girls
baiting pedos at 10 yeah that's that
couldn't be dangerous at all just sit on
our porch and laugh only one time there
was like he was probably like 19 maybe
he wasn't too old and he kept walking up
and down the street and he's seen us on
her porch and asked us about something
about the house and we're like oh I
don't know who lives there but that was
the only time we ever like interacted
with them but usually they would just
drive around the block and then keep
looking and you they didn't want to do
it but they had that urge where they
would do it like they would go up to
this house it looks abandoned it's dark
there's Vines everywhere there was like
boards and you still went up there like
that's how powerful it had like it's
yeah yeah yeah yeah and and that's back
then like we're saying now the ease of
access now is dude Rosen had some uh guy
trying to meet get kids to meet him at
his church
while he was at church yeah fun fact the
only episode he ever wore pants because
because he was going to a church he
always wears basketball shirts and a
regular like [__] under armor shirt
it was the only Predator poetry ever
wore jeans because he's like well we're
going into a church
let's show some decorum oh kind of trash
going back to the Roblox thing she
brought Leanne was said uh Roblox is
super bad there's also private modded
servers where they have animated sex act
oh so it's becoming like second life
right it's what it's what I'm reading
that shit's [__] wild and I can't
dude I'm sorry but this breastfeeding
thing is still [__] me up yeah it's
literally you there's a there's all I
just just just Google breastfeeding Tick
Tock there's uh [__] lot and a lot of
these children look like they're at
least in first grade
yeah I like watched one for like 10-15
minutes just to to see like what is are
you giving tips or no no and then she
started talking about her only fans
that's how I know I was like are you
[__] mentioning your only fans right
now I was like oh my God this is so
disturbing I reported it but I guarantee
nothing happened no it's but the other
thing is it's not even it's a monster
like like how do you how do you even go
after like like Marsh was saying like
there's there's a bunch oh there's a way
well no there's a way
I'm like dude you have to pay attention
to this [__] like it's not it's you're
giving them like it's open season on
your kids dude like they will find a way
and it's wild there is like you said
Church like from working because I do
work with sex traffic victims from that
and dancing and stripping dude the most
perverted people were highly religious
because they use it as a shield to abuse
people over and over and over again so
yeah you gotta watch there too
yeah trust me that's that one guy that
was like a a huge pedophile um oh my God
I can't remember his name they had like
shows on him where he was working Jimmy
Savile like physically huge or prolific
I can't remember his name those gigantic
pedophile he stood 10 feet tall but he
was in like church and doing mission
right right and like abusing these poor
kids like over in Vietnam I think and
other places like that but he was with a
Church of course he was like they always
use that well church or schools or
anywhere you have access right anywhere
anywhere you have authority I think is
the best way to put it anywhere you have
like and it also sucks because they've
tainted like legitimate mentorships
that's right like there used to be the
Big Brother program there used to be you
know there used to be dudes that like
maybe they were like used to be an
athlete and now they were you know
whatever they got an extra day off week
they go out like you know help some kids
with their baseball pitching and stuff
nobody wants to Mentor anybody anymore
because nobody wants to get called a
pedo so now even all the on like now
we're at the point in society where if
anyone's hanging around little kids just
[__] locked them up because at this
point even well-meaning people are like
hey like even if it's a friend it's like
hey can you come over and teach my kid
like some stuff about baseball on you're
like you're gonna be there the whole
time right because I don't want any
[__] well when you only CK had that
joke when he when he found he found the
Lost kid in like the the subway yeah and
he was like I had to hold the kid's hand
because I don't want the kid to get lost
but I don't want to walk up to parents
with bald redheaded idiot holding a
kid's hand and it's like it sucks though
because that it turns like even turns
well-meaning people into like you know
like if I'm in a store and a kid comes
up and it's like mister I'm lost I would
probably start screaming security like I
was being assaulted I'd be like say
can't go over here I know I'm not
happened at the airport there was a guy
and his wife and a little girl and she
like slipped on the escalator and like
almost fell and my guy friend that was
with me I was like you you should have
like grabbed or at least tried he's like
no I'm scared to I don't want to touch
his kid I'm like you're gonna let her
get eaten by like a escalator and
instead of just trying to help yeah but
yeah and the answer is yes yeah you want
to register as a sex offender or watch
this escalator violently eat a child I'm
going with the ladder now I don't want
to go to prison uh I was like oh my God
that's so sad like I get it but it's
just